all right well the guy that's got to
come correct tonight
is rick porcello signed a one-year 10
million dollar deal last five seasons
with the red sox cy young in 16. so
runners at the corners two men out and
here comes big city matt adams the d.h
swinging a
line drive base hit in a left center
field that will score the game's first
run
ozzy crosses and it's one to nothing
atlanta
adams foils the shift with a line drive
on the third base side of second
it's to swanson he's swung on and hit in
the air to shallow center field racing
in his nemo
he'll have to play it on a bounce
another run is in sliding in at third
is adams and he is out freeman scoring
easily
on the rbi single by swanson from big
sean nukem
you know his problem was he just
couldn't throw enough strikes couldn't
go deep enough
into the game so two down down and
here's conforto two aboard braves
leading it two to nothing we're the
bottom of the first check swing tapper
up along
third handled by riley steps on the bag
and newcomb gets out of it
and with the panel leading two to
nothing they have runners at the corners
one out
and back to the top of the order for
ronald acuna jr it's broken bad chopper
to third up with it mcneal fires to
second one kanota first
double play side retired and there's
that signature sinker
of rick porcello getting the job done
with two outs
a man aboard for brandon nemo one and
two the count
now the pitch swinging a high fly ball
well hit to left going back to zunya
on the run at the wall the one hops the
wall a base hit for nimmo
in the score is nito nimo to second
holds there with a double and a run
batted in the mitz are on the board
and the braves lead is cut to 2-1 so
it's first and second
nobody out for marcel ozuna porcello
rares back and fires
and it's hit in the air to left field
racing back as davis over his head
in one hops the fence all these will
score
freddy freeman is going to stop at third
base
so it's an rbi double for marcel ozuna
and the braves lead is now
three to one so the bases are loaded
with braves
one run already in still nobody out
dansby swanson at the plate
oh one pitch hit hard on the air left
field over the head
of j.d davis one run is in ozuna's going
to score
and standing at second with a double is
dansby swanson
it's a 5-1 game corey oswalt coming in
rick porcello
night is over and the braves have loaded
the bases again
and an opportunity here for endurance
ciarte hit in the air and hit well to
right conforto going back
it is over his head is at the base of
the fence one run will score
swanson will score riley will stop at
third base and standing at second with a
two-run double
is inderenciarte it's 7-1 so newcomb
with runners at the corners and two men
out will face jd davis ground ball hit
to short dansby has it underhands to all
these and
ends the third inning and freeman still
at second base
7-1 braves on top here's the payoff
pitch to swanson
on the way swung on hit in the air to
right field and deep
and forto was playing shallow he looks
up that ball is out of here home run
dansby swanson
opposite field with a two run homer and
the braves are on top
nine to one it's all braves
9-1 but here's albie's now next pitch to
ozzy swung on
that's ripped to right field back goes
conforto he misjudged that one and it
sailed over his head
and went to the wall there's another
double that scores a cunha and that
makes it
to one ozone is one for three with a
double and rbi and a run scored
who delivers the pitch swung on and hit
high and deep to left field we may have
a winner that ball
is gone home run ozuna his fourth extra
base hit in the series his second home
run
and the braves are on top 11-1
that was a no doubter
that one is hammered left field way out
of here
austin riley look out off the facade of
that top
deck my goodness
and the braves unloading on the mets
this ball
is absolutely annihilated
at the plate high fly ball hit to deep
center field nemo going back
looking up and that one is gone ozzy
albee's to dead
center his third extra base hit it's
13-1
grant dayton tries to get the final
three outs
swinging a miss fastball at the top of
the strike zone payoff pitch
swinging a mess struck him out so dayton
looks sharp
so jimenez will bat next for the mets
hit in the air to left field this is
going to be a playable for adam duvall
and the braves finish off the route
of the new york mets the braves win
their first series
in 2020 two games to one dramatic
victory in game two
and not much drama in this one